[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
traveling beyond the confines of the uk
and taking a look at the global
wizarding community in the harry potter
books and films were more or less
confined to a couple of places within
the uk
and that was our primary introduction to
the wizarding world however when the
fantastic beast films came out the
wizarding world as we know it began
expanding showing us new countries and
magical places in fact much of the
fantastic beasts films so far have taken
place in america and france with the
next installment bringing us all over
the place with our ever-growing
knowledge of other wizarding countries i
find it particularly interesting how the
wizarding culture differs from place to
place and in today's video i'm going to
be honing in on one particular aspect of
that culture
the school system because you see
hogwarts though granted the potentially
biased honor of the world's greatest
magic school isn't the only option for
witches and wizards around the globe
today i want to open your eyes to the
rest of them at least the ones we know
about anyway as it turns out there are
11 established wizarding schools in
total at least 11 that are officially
registered with the international
confederation of wizards the primary
governing body there are others but they
aren't as official or regulated and we
don't know much about those ones
now i know what you might be thinking 11
schools for the whole world that's it
well pottermore has a fair explanation
for this
affairs relating to magical schooling
are handled by the educational office of
the international confederation of
wizards who can direct people to their
nearest school however the majority of
magical communities choose to homeschool
young witches and wizards which is why
there are so few schools in comparison
to the number of countries
alternatively some witches and wizards
might take correspondence courses which
may prove a cheaper option in countries
that are too small to have their own
school okay so there are 11 official
wizarding schools a few unofficial
schools and a significant population of
home-schooled students now there's just
one thing left to answer what are these
11 schools which countries are they in
how do they differ from hogwarts let's
get into it castelo brushu i'm going to
kick things off with castelo brushu
mainly as it's this school that we
should expect to see in the upcoming
fantastic beasts film the secrets of
dumbledore castelo brushu is a brazilian
wizarding school that's located amid the
amazon rainforest in northern brazil and
it's home to students from all over
south america the school itself is just
as old as hogwarts at least according to
pottermore and was founded 500 years
before colonization the physical
structure of the school forms an
imposing square of golden rock that
resembles a temple but to muggle eyes
the school is simply a pile of ruins
protected by enchantments much like
hogwarts according to pottermore
protecting the school grounds are
caipora
small and furry mischievous spirit
beings that watch over the students and
creatures within the forest surrounding
the school like hogwarts the south
american student body of castelo brushu
wear a uniform however their uniform can
be easily identified by the bright green
robes outlined with patterns including
yellow lines red rings and blue
triangles it has also been expressed
that the students of the school are
particularly versed in the subjects of
herbology and major zoology
we don't know for sure if the school is
going to be in the fantastic beasts
franchise but we do know that armando
dippit the hogwarts headmaster preceding
dumbledore meets with the headmistress
of castelo brushu benedita dorado
sometime in the twentieth century
which could potentially overlap with the
film timeline called foreign
is the wizarding school of russia and
one of eleven schools registered with
the international confederation of
wizards the name comes from the russian
words called
meaning witchcraft and tavarez which
means creator if we overlap the two
words they form a portmento which means
the creator of magic makes sense for a
wizarding school there isn't much
information available out there on the
school and this is because jk rowling
despite including it in the official
list of wizarding schools decided not to
publish much additional information on
this particular academic institution
however this lack of information has
forced fans to get exceptionally
creative which has resulted in the
following fan published and unofficial
school details including the school
being located on a hidden section of
lake lodoga a freshwater lake located in
northwestern russia the school having a
protective barrier surrounding it and
the school having a house system with
houses instead being referred to as
courts that are represented by coral
pink turquoise and amber the only canon
information that we have on the cordov's
is that they have their own version of
quidditch where instead of flying on
brums they fly on entire uprooted trees
dermstrang dermstrang which you've
probably heard of before think copper to
fire bears the darkest reputation of all
wizarding schools and was once home to
infamous dark wizard gelet grindelwald
before he was expelled for experimenting
with twisted magic aside from students
and staff of the school no one knows
exactly where darmstrang is other than
that it's located somewhere in the far
north of europe this is because visitors
of the school must comply with having
memory charms performed on them in order
to erase their knowledge of how they
arrived there according to pottermore
visitors of the school speak of vast
sprawling grounds with many stunning
views not least of the great dark
spectral ship that is moored on a
mountain lake behind the school from
which students dive in summertime
dermstrang was originally founded during
the middle ages by a bulgarian witch
named narida volkanova she successfully
operated the school until her mysterious
death at which point she was succeeded
by hafeng munter a wizard who
established the school's reputation for
its emphasis on martial magic
later in the school's future dark wizard
and former death eater eagle kakaroth
became head master of the school at
which point he promoted a culture of
fear and intimidation further
contributing to the school's dark
reputation
upon karkarov's assumption of power many
parents withdrew their students from the
school
the students of durmstrang wore fur
cloaks fur hats and blood red robes
ilvermorny in 2016 jk rowling published
a lengthy origin story for ilvermorny
school
north america's school of witchcraft and
wizardry if you want to know the whole
thing check out my video in the pinned
comment as for now i'm just going to be
providing a brief summary ilvermorny was
founded in the early 17th century by
izolt sayer an irish pureblood witch the
only child and daughter of william and
reanaxer and the wife of james steward
together with her husband they founded
ilvermorny school and established its
four houses
thunderbird wampus horned serpent and
pakwaji ilvermorny can be described as
follows the great north american school
of magic was founded in the 17th century
it stands at the highest peak of mount
greylock where it is concealed from
non-magic gaze by a variety of powerful
enchantments which sometimes manifest in
a wreath of misty cloud the school
started as a zolt and james simply
teaching their adopted children in a
small cottage but over the years their
operation began to grow
eventually becoming a fully-fledged
educational institution
per pottermore ilvermorny's reputation
continued to increase over the years and
it eventually became a boarding school
taking in students from across north
america more teachers were hired to meet
the demand and the house was expanded to
a castle
by the 19th century it had gained an
international reputation and by the
1920s it was considered one of the
greatest wizarding schools in the world
the current head teacher of ilvermorny
is aglebert fontaine the direct
descendant of one of the 12 original
macusa auras assault and james both
lived to be over 100 they had seen the
cottage of ilvermorny become a granite
castle and they died in the knowledge
that their school was now so famous that
magical families all over north america
were clamoring to educate their children
there they had hired staff they had
built dormitories they'd concealed their
school from no magis by clever
enchantments in short the girl who had
dreamed of attending hogwarts had helped
found the north american equivalent
bobator bobator academy of magic was
founded sometime in the 13th century by
an unknown witch or wizard the school
can be found somewhere in the pyrenees
mountains of southern france and is home
to witches and wizards of many different
nationalities the school itself is said
to be stunning in nature complete with
majestic gardens and a magical fountain
which is said to possess healing and
beautifying properties some speculate
that part of the school's impressive
physical appearance can be attributed to
donations from one of its former pupils
nicola flamel also known as the creator
of the philosopher's stone
the school's coat of arms isn't so bad
to look at either with two golden ones
crossed over one another firing three
stars you should already know a little
about beautiful as it's referenced in
the harry potter books quite a bit
particularly in the goblet of fire where
they compete against hogwarts and
dermstrang in the triwizard tournament
we also have a pretty good grasp of the
students as fleur de la cour ends up
being a recurring character
the school uniform for bobaton is
comprised of pale blue robes made of
fine silk along with a pale blue hat and
the current head mistress for bobatore
is none other than madame olimpe maxime
also known as hagrid's love interest a
half giant witch who seems to maintain
quite a good relationship with the
student body mahutu koro mahutukuro is
the japanese school of magic located on
the topmost point of the volcanic island
of manima iwo jima
it's unknown when exactly the school was
founded but many speculate that it is
one of the oldest wizarding schools only
described as ancient this ancient
japanese school has the smallest student
body of the 11 great wizarding schools
and take students from the age of seven
although they do not board until they
are eleven while day students visiting
children are flown back and forth to
their homes every day on the backs for
flock of giant storm petrols
the ornate and exquisite palace of
mahutukuro is made of mutton fat jade
and stands on the topmost point of the
uninhabited alsa mugglestink volcanic
island of minami iwo jima in my opinion
mahutukuro has the most interesting
dress code of all the schools as the
colours size of the robes they wear are
dynamic in nature this is described on
pottermore students are presented with
enchanted robes when they arrive which
grow in size as they do and which
gradually change color as the learning
of their wearer increases beginning a
faint pink color and becoming if top
grades are achieved in every magical
subject gold if the robes turn white
this is an indication that the student
has portrayed the japanese wizards code
and adopted illegal practices which in
europe we call dark magic
or broken the international statute of
secrecy to turn white is a terrible
disgrace which results in instant
expulsion from the school and a trial at
the japanese ministry for magic
students of mohotokoro typically used
ones crafted out of cherrywood and the
school itself is known for its
impressive academic prowess as well as
its outstanding reputation for quidditch
interestingly even with the small
student body this is the only known
school in asia which could suggest that
some asian witches and wizards will also
attend koldov storiets in russia wagadu
wakardu is a wizarding school located in
what are called the mountains of the
moon an ancient term referring to the
ruenzori mountains of uganda founded the
source of the nile river the school
located in the mountain range has been
described as a stunning edifice carved
out of the mountainside shrouded in mist
so that it sometimes appeared simply to
float in mid-air
the exact founding year of the school is
unknown however we do know that the
school has been around for about 1 000
years making it similar in age to
hogwarts despite many other smaller
wizarding schools popping up all over
africa over the centuries it has been
expressed that wagadu is the only one to
withstand the test of time making it the
largest wizarding school in africa and
even the world students receive notice
that they have gained entrance at wagadu
from dream messengers sent by the
headmaster or headmistress of the day
the dream messenger will appear to the
children as they sleep and relieve a
token usually an inscribed stone which
is found in the child's hand on waking
no other school employs this method of
pupil selection the students of wakadu
are said to be particularly versed in
the areas of astronomy alchemy
self-transfiguration and wandless magic
as the wand was primarily a european
invention witches and wizards of africa
learned to channel their magic without
any kind of instrument
furthermore it has been expressed that
the students of ogardu are able to
become anime guy at an exceedingly young
age which is especially impressive if we
consider that becoming an animagus is
very rare in the uk
not much is known about the school's
uniforms or whether any kind of house
system is used hogwarts hogwarts have
you heard of it was founded at some
point during the 10th century
it was built hidden off somewhere in the
scottish highlands the exact location is
never actually revealed and this was
because the 10th century was a time of
hardship for witches and wizards during
this time every day witches and wizards
were being persecuted by muggles who
were intensely hostile when it came to
witnessing sources of magic in order to
further protect the staff students and
school itself additional precautions
were made in the form of charms helping
to further conceal the school from
muggle trespassers if a muggle were to
just happen to stumble upon the school
grounds they would only see ruins and
signs warning them to stay away
hogwarts was founded when four 10th
century witches and wizards got together
and decided that they had in the sorting
hat's own words the self-same yearning
to make the world's best magic school
these founders were godric gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw salazar therein and
helga hufflepuff thus hogwarts was born
the name hogwarts actually came from
founder rowena ravenclaw who had a dream
where a warty hog led her to a cliff by
a lake it's also been speculated that
this is how they chose the location for
the school as well
after its establishment like with any
institution a crest was formed for
hogwarts emblazoned upon the school
crest to the words draco dormian nancome
which roughly translates to never tickle
a sleeping dragon after the founders
founded the school they decided that
they would each create and head their
own house which would represent a
personality trait and skill that they
wanted to nurture
and it just so happened that despite
being close friends each founder
happened to value very different things
which created quite an interesting and
diverse array of students at the school
gryffindor students embodied bravery and
chivalry
ravenclaw intelligence and wit
hufflepuff loyalty and fair play and
slytherin the values of being sly and
cunning and that's it for the named
wizarding schools i know that i said
that there were 11 official wizarding
schools and there are but these are the
only ones that we have any information
on
according to pottermore there is an
australian wizarding school which we
have no information on and two more
visiting schools at undisclosed
locations maybe we'll get this
information in the future and with that
i'm going to end the video did you learn
much about these other wizarding schools
which school do you live closest to
which school would you attend if you had
a choice leave a comment down below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]